ici le 911 comment puis-je vous avez
monsieur j'ai besoin de savoir où vous
êtes afin de pouvoir vous envoyer de
l'aide
[Musique]
est ce que tu vas bien
je tout va bien sergent
la sauver la vie de ces petites filles
ce soir
peu de gens se rendent compte de
l'énorme fardeau que nous portons que
d'arborer la signent
ça fait partie de notre boulot
tu ferais bien te ramener nos frères une
enquête
nous avons reçu des informations
déroutantes
l'appel était un canular
comment des trucs pareils arrive je n'ai
entendu crier depuis la rue je les
jugeais sur son apparence c'est une
affaire très complexe c'était un mari un
père tu peux pas la laisser comme ça je
ne sais pas quoi lui dire et les choses
bien bouge ton cul
je viens dans le cadre d'une enquête sur
un homicide un homme est mort le suspect
est toujours en cavale
quand on travaille je ne veux pas
entraîné dans cette chute tu ne
m'entraîne n'ont rien je ne sais pas
déjà si ton épouse dix mois ce qui se
passe
[Musique]
c'est pas son autorisation je pourrai
pas lui venir en aide
il faut qu'on parle je sais quel genre
de fille tu es
tu crois que ça fait quoi pour un
terrain vague sur quelqu'un a du mal à
respirer ton coeur s'accélère quand on
vous qui bavent des oreilles
il a rendu son dernier souffle angoissé
et tout seul
il faut leur rendre justice
[Musique]